foreign
hey guys and welcome to a yet another
super cold production episode of
congratulations
[Music]
another one it's another one who does
another another one that's [ __ ] DJ
Khaled don't know a lot of these rappers
a lot of these rappers say a lot of
stupid [ __ ] but it's all good and he's
just a producer my baby so uh that's
what's going on dude welcome to another
episode of congratulations and I want to
talk to you a little bit about something
about [ __ ] original grain dude check
out this man they sent me this watch
which is very cool
um burl wood silver
burlwood silver 44 millimeter Chrono
made of rare rugged
burl wood rugged
you like rugged you like rugged stuff
dude
um look at that looks cool with my
tattoo
so don't sleep on that
um large watch face because I'm a real
man and I'm killing it with the watch
baby
um great blend of style and
functionality you want style and
functionality you come to original crane
um yeah does it come with a stopwatch
Timing System and a calendar date
function
um yeah it does
and the back of the watch can be
engraved with a personalized message
perfect for Christmas and weddings and
anniversaries and birthdays so I don't
know he seems like a no-brainer to me
original grain sunglasses are also back
in stock because those sell at lightning
speeds so go to
originalgrain.com
congrats and use code congrats for 30
off for our listeners you welcome
did it for you link is below uh in the
description in the show description so
anyway dude killing it with style and
functionality and and rugged burlwood
dude you ever have some rugged burl wood
on your wrist look at that nice
you ever dangle you watch like that
looks cool whatever dude I'm just
chilling you know what I mean and we're
having a good time and it's hot as [ __ ]
in here
let's do it already hot and it's
September 20. it's almost my Mommy's
birthday my Mommy's birthday was a few
days ago
this came out I say almost because I'm
recording it beforehand and when this
comes out it will have passed and that's
just how time works
um but that's all good
um we got the life rips jackets dude
they've been [ __ ] selling hard I did
not know they would be selling hard but
man I can't wait to see them at the
shows I see all your merches at the
shows dude it's killing and remember to
get the merch go to chrislea.com get all
the you get the Periwinkle [ __ ] to get
the brown shits you get it all and you
wear it at other people's
stand-up shows look at that dude
played the same place Metallica played
uh the other day uh for I guess you know
I don't know I'm a [ __ ]
I'm a I'm a metal band is that a metal
Metallica I guess so metallic metallic
is metal so
um yeah but uh did it and uh
and did that and was played in Oakland
played in Stockton
uh Stockton is I I actually have some
clips I'm gonna put on my other YouTube
channel the Chrisley channel uh like And
subscribe by the way we can't break
580 596 000 on this [ __ ] uh YouTube
channel which is kind of [ __ ] crazy
weird something going on with the shadow
band I don't know I hate when people say
shadow band because it's like mostly
just like it's not Shadow band it's
mostly just you suck but very weird to
gain thousands and thousands of his
subscribers and then all of a sudden
don't
um but whatever dude I'm not a
conspiracy theorist yes Joe Biden is a
lizard perhaps but uh what I am saying
is I played Stockton and uh I roasted
Stockton a little bit
uh just for fun for funsies you know I
don't know what's up with my my tour
manager but he's sending me to Stockton
and also Rockford Illinois which is
worse than Chicago when it comes to
getting your week you're wait wait push
back Playa
um so going Rockford Illinois get your
wig push back player get your wig push
back get get get yeah head out yes
Playboy and um that's a real song and so
uh power 106. get get your head out yes
Playboy
um
so yeah so I uh I played Stockton
um and and it's a dangerous area I mean
literally they told us don't go out
don't go at dude we rolled into Stockton
we flew in first of all we flew into
Sacramento where you're at
and uh Sacramento where you at Dr Dre
I remember one time when I was in high
school he goes He we were listening to
it Sacramento where you at and I was
with my friend Brendan goody and I said
oh hey Dr Dre you ever tried checking
Sacramento
I did and he laughed so hard what a bad
joke dude and so um
so I played um by the way thank you for
listening I'm very grateful you guys are
here feeling grateful today
um
uh so my my tour manager Enrique which
Calvin calls rikay he says uh well let's
fly into Sacramento let's go to Stockton
we'll drive there we won't get a room
because we'll just be there before the
show for a few hours and then we will
leave we'll do the show leave Stockton
and go to Oakland right there because we
shouldn't stay in Stockton because it's
dangerous and I'm like how about we just
don't play War zones
you know how about we just play Oakland
and then do maybe San Francisco now
granted now is San Francisco a place
where you will see people sitting on the
street yes is it a place where you where
you will see people breaking not only
into places but also out of places yes
is it a place where you see multiple
people crying alone in their parked
Vehicles yes is it a place where you
will see guys [ __ ] each other on the
streets a yes has have I seen it all yes
is it always freezing no matter what
even if it's inogony yeah August yes now
does that make it a [ __ ] hell on
Earth does it make it where [ __ ] they
filmed Strange Days starring finds hey
yes
but
is it all good no it's not all good and
I don't like that place but it's a
little bit less dangerous than Stockton
because you might get your wig Bush back
in Stockton right and we got so I said
okay whatever we did it get to Stockton
now Stockton's one of those places that
of course you have to walk around
because you got to get something to eat
especially if you're an added Tanner
especially if you're going to be
performing in five hours you can't not
eat right
so I get to the [ __ ]
uh
place and I'm like let's walk around for
food now there's one Greek restaurant
now I don't like Greek food I don't like
Mediterranean food to me it all tastes
the same have I tried it a bunch yes do
people think that I'm narrow-minded and
I need to try some more yes
but I've tried it a bunch of times and I
don't like it I like Greek salads and
that's it but I'm not in the muffler
Greek salad I'm a growing boy right I
need to get some you know what I mean
like give me a hefty sandwich or
something and so
we say what's the best place to eat and
somebody says that Greek restaurant we
go into the Greek restaurant it's closed
it's 1 40 p.m yes what lunch place
closes at [ __ ] 1 40 p.m up front yes
yes is it running drugs yes no doubt
dude so it's closed so they say so I say
to the bus boy what's another good place
points to another place down the street
and he says you in a Mexican and I said
sure whatever I mean not really for
lunch you know like if you're a white
guy that eats Mexican for lunch your
day's done after that you know eating
three enchiladas and [ __ ] and then just
what going back to work bro I'm sleeping
after that man dude you want to put a
[ __ ] what like a a carne asada burrito
in your belly and then go back to work
crazy [ __ ] man eat a burrito at 7 30 on
and then that's it your night's over
okay
like it's the most [ __ ] so but I'm
like look whatever bro it's early enough
before the show I'll take a little bit
of a nap right and then I'll have the
you know I'll have the you know I'll
drink some coffee it'll be fine so say
sure put me in the direction of the
Mexican restaurant push me to the
direction of the Mexican restaurant the
Greek guy well he was Mexican too even
though he was at a Greek restaurant but
um and he was like down there and we go
down there walk in it's now 145. lights
are off it's [ __ ] clouds dude so
that's two restaurants at 1 45 p.m that
are just [ __ ] closed on Friday
it's a work day Stockton it's a front
dude multiple people have gotten their
wigs pushed back in these restaurants no
doubt right
so I go what the [ __ ] dude so now I ask
another guy outside and I say is there
another place and it got points oh no no
wait that's not what happened I say all
right you know what Google it and call
him I say to one of my guys that I'm
with right now I am a diva I try not to
be a diva but if two places are closed
and I got the [ __ ] hungrys guess what
dude shape-shifted into a diva okay
where are these places call ahead of
time make sure they're open all right so
we do it now
my [ __ ] dude one of my buddies is on
Yahoo or uh Yelp and my other buddy is
on [ __ ] Google Maps we're trying to
triangulate where we go so Mike linochi
hilarious comedian that's working with
me
Google's a place and he goes this place
looks bomb and I say yeah and he shows
me the [ __ ] shows me pictures the
pictures are from Yelp probably I have
no idea could be from Google Images I
have no idea now are the [ __ ]
sandwiches banging that would be a 100
yes do they look a bit unhealthy yes now
have I been eating shitty 100 I gotta
keeps it lean but I can't when I'm on
the road a lot you know your boy will
eat multiple burgers and lots of red
meats okay I don't want to do that I
don't want to die early but if I'm at a
burger place I'm gonna get a burger I'm
not gonna get the chicken bowl because
I'm here because we went to a burger
place and am I gonna get cheese on my
fries yeah dude all right because I want
to live it up I'm on the road
and uh you know I'm not [ __ ]
so I'm gonna get the cheese fries
I told my therapist hey look I'm really
trying to eat healthier but it's really
hard not to eat sweets and she literally
goes whoa whoa one thing at a time you
gotta live somehow and I go oh [ __ ] I'm
getting the [ __ ]
so I say all right dude
cheese fries on
anyway dude the guy points oh no so uh
wow totally went [ __ ] totally brain
farted that's not the part of the story
I was at so um
I mean Jesus Christ how did I do that
that is insane that is literally another
story that I was gonna tell so the guy
points [ __ ] and so there he got all
the Infinity Stones anyway
so um just in the middle of a [ __ ]
Schindler's List Thanos uh all right so
so Mike's like these sandwiches look
banging so I'm like all right let's live
it up dude let's [ __ ] live it up dude
now you know me you know me I like to
order it a counter get a number sit down
at whatever the [ __ ] place I'm at
whatever table we choose and have them
bring the food or call and I go get it
those are my spots dude those are my f
those are my spots
okay do I like to sit do I like to sit
down and get an order taken I'm not
really into that it's more of a formal
thing and if I'm on the road I like to
run and Gun it but if I have to and
options are limited I'll sit down and
the waiter can come by and I'll tell
them what I want but my [ __ ] is to be
like this to a menu
um
and then I say the thing and then they
go
here they give me a number or a [ __ ]
one of those
that don't ring for some reason they're
way loud or vibrating you know like just
they're so loud those discs that [ __ ]
Cheesecake Factory give you it's like
just make it ring
yeah it's on the table it says
and you're oh [ __ ] it's like someone
stepped on a goddamn land mine
okay I guess we're ready I wish it rang
so or just text me you know so
like it's 2022. so
um so then I'm like all right well look
those sandwiches look bang and let's
just go there
we're walking we're walking now it's hot
as [ __ ]
and I got you know my pits are getting
activated my armpits are activated
armpits colon activated
and uh swamp ass colon activated and so
I got swamp passed and you know my
armpits are activated and
um we're walking
um
and we are
rolling up to the place
and we walk well out of our way
and Enrique looks up and he says oh
that's a an hour a block away we've
walked multiple blocks in the [ __ ]
rip run heat trying to get our Wig wigs
pushed back right
and when Ricky looks up and says oh
it's a food truck
files done
bro uh I'm I mean
I'm gonna get a [ __ ]
Monte Cristo sandwich and just stand
around you know
I'm just gonna
yeah let me get and it's so and there's
misters you know what I mean with a fan
one of those [ __ ] little ones that
are more annoying and I'm and I'm gonna
say uh Monte Cristo and it's so hot with
the tin and then with the tin foil and
then eat it on the side of the road and
while I [ __ ] and some guy's gonna
drive by in a low rider and just pop and
my wait wait is gonna get pushed back
and I'm gonna die with [ __ ] Monte
Cristo sandwich all over myself yeah
right dude miles done no [ __ ] way
dude
I want a place where I can order it so I
look to the note I'm [ __ ] really
a food truck why are there even food
trucks on Yelp don't they move
I don't like food trucks that are
stationary because just get a place
like you're cheating the system do you
know what I'm talking about like if
you're in a play if you're stationary so
much as a food truck that you get to be
on Yelp
get a [ __ ] building
he cheat in the taxes probably we're
probably gonna pay the city is Stockton
is probably all you know if they got rid
of these food trucks the city will
probably do better and they'll be less
[ __ ] whiz getting pushed back player
so now I'm like oh good I got extra
swamp ass to look at a [ __ ] food
because we're not going here
and then he goes ah [ __ ] well at least
we didn't walk that extra block and I go
Silver Lining that silver lining is
[ __ ]
so he's like let me look so we look
again and there's another Mexican I'm
like what's up with all these [ __ ]
Mexicans there's so many Mexican
restaurants and Stockton is Mexican and
but bro it is so white
like it's like that kind of white where
a white guy's like hey where hey hey
what's up you're like oh [ __ ] what all
the tattoos and he's five foot eight you
know with a hat with the brim that's to
the side but straight oh [ __ ]
we get those pants at uh what just that
kind of guy
so I'm like all right well you know I
already got swamp ass I can't take a
shower because we don't have a [ __ ]
room there's a shower in the theater but
who the [ __ ] uses that besides Slipknot
and Mud Vein do you know what I mean
like who uses the showers in the theater
besides slip knot Mud Vein and probably
a weirdo like Jason Mraz
you know
just [ __ ] well you know me I like to
take a shower before the show and just
Jack Johnson probably uses it too I saw
Jason Mraz on [ __ ] Sesame Street the
other day and I'm like all right Calvin
was watching it Mr a to the Z
and uh what's that [ __ ]
but I'm bound
if you did that and didn't do words the
song would be equally as successful so
um
anyway
uh
uh so anyway uh but [ __ ] I'm like all
right let's go to this other Mexican
restaurant call to see if it's [ __ ]
open because it's open so we get there
and it's one of my spots baby dude hell
yeah man it's literally one of those
[ __ ] spots where you just order at
the counter and just [ __ ] sit they
give you a number and I'm just like
sensation
and
so we get the thing and this is the best
because Enrique is Mexican you know what
I mean which I'm just like I don't
really think about ever because I know
look I know you're not supposed to say
this you're not supposed to say I don't
see color because you're supposed to see
color and you're supposed to be like
okay and acknowledge the color and
respect the differences and move on and
still be cool with it and you're like
like black people don't like I don't
like see color because you were like
[ __ ] I'm black respect the
Blackness and I'm just like cool I
respect the Blackness right
respect to Blackness is a very good
title for the episode
um
but uh
I you know I know he's Mexican but I
don't ever think about it okay but so
we're at a Mexican restaurant okay and I
didn't think about it I don't think
about when I walk in I don't think about
oh hey we're in a Mexican restaurant
that's cool we got to Mexico with us
like I'm not a [ __ ] racist
and I see color but I don't see that
much color right so I'm like we walk in
and we're all doing the thing to the
menu my [ __ ] which we're looking at the
menu just like we're doing like this and
I go quick bro I look one [ __ ] thing
at the menu and I go boom I probably
want this burrito chicken burrito let's
house that right let's go ahead give it
to me on a place plate I'm gonna house
that
okay I'm gonna eat it like this
[Music]
I'm housing it okay put chicken in put
what comes on this [ __ ] I say let me get
the chicken burrito and then look under
it and I say chicken supreme burrito it
says and you get guacamole in that and
cheese and I'm like I'll get that how's
that let me let me house that right
let me [ __ ] throw it up to where
there's a burrito outline in my neck for
a little bit and then it Wiggles and
then goes back down let me house that
burrito okay
so
now I pretend I'll pretend the [ __ ]
burrito is some homeless people
and how's it okay
I'll pretend that burrito is a homeless
child and all house it
all right
are you a runaway are you filled with
chicken and guacamole done Matt either
way I'll house it
laughs
uh
so anyway
I get the thing and I say burrito
chicken with the [ __ ] guacamole you
know me but I go no sour cream because
that's the kind of [ __ ] dude I am
because guess what I don't ever want in
a burrito white cream all right
so I go like this oh [ __ ] chicken
supreme burrito let me house that she
goes sure then Mike lenochi orders sure
then my [ __ ] cameraman orders whitest
dude on the planet Sam he goes uh let me
have you know
[ __ ] I don't know I got the wrong
thing Mike linoche and him they order
wrong and then Enrique steps up and he's
just like
and I'm like hey guy go first
hook us up
you're gonna do this all along hook us
hey guy hook it up walk in and be like I
got this uh me me me me me
okay
and we're just [ __ ] whiten it up uh
yeah and the guacamole is another sour
cream and dude Enrique comes in like
[ __ ] done one day Stockton okay
just [ __ ] uh
[Music]
and I'm just like okay for real I look
at him and he's like what I'm like for
real bro
[ __ ] it up so
you know
then she's a [ __ ] uh yeah you know
Jesus Christ you know and [ __ ]
Spanish
you know
and so we get it I'm just like dude you
know everybody better stop making a
mistake because I'm a [ __ ] Diva on
the road dude don't turn me into a diva
uh so we get to [ __ ] so we eat the
[ __ ] and boy did I [ __ ] house that I
swear to God
I mean it was just so big the burrito
was so big and then La note she's like
oh [ __ ] man you want to trade half and
half and I'm like I don't do that [ __ ]
bro I order what I want I'm not I'm not
a [ __ ] I'm not like one of these
[ __ ] that's like oh yeah dude I
know what I want I'm not gonna I don't
second guess when it comes to food in my
mouth man I know it's getting housed so
you know and then he's like man and then
I said what is that out of 10 and he
goes I don't know like an eight and then
he says what's yours and I go mine's a
9.5 and he goes really and I'm like yep
he's like I want to trade and I say nope
I don't want to trade bro and then he's
like all right let me just try yours
I'll try it and I tried it and it was a
six I'm like this is an eight anyway
dude
when I order I'm [ __ ] that's why I
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
um
so now we go back to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then we're chilling at the uh show
I took a little bit of a nap and I don't
you know and then I do the show and then
and before the show Enrique is like oh
um
yeah it's crazy we're not staying here
we're going to Oakland and we go to
Oakland I'm just going to run in and get
your keys and then bring it back out of
the car so you can just go and I got
security for you I'm like huh who the
[ __ ] am I like the vice president
and he was like yeah well it's because
there's been seven people have been shot
in the last two days in Oakland and I'm
like oh well then
so you know that's what it is I made it
out to flames dude we made it out we
made it out of the [ __ ] Yay Area
uh we beat the rap what kibi talak webe
to rap what kibi tala
I played that song for Calvin when I got
home the E40 song and he liked he goes I
like that song
so
um anyway dude that was what was up and
that was the shows were great dude
um they had the [ __ ] mask mandates
for the Oakland and I love that nobody
had the masks on dude nobody had masks
on I saw one mask in the audience it was
[ __ ] absolutely illen top villain
dude it was Dylan top villain
um
anyway
um
wow it's the 250 and 75th
episode that is just crazy
how crazy is that
um
I don't really uh is that TV too loud no
it's not too loud is it I don't really
know about the uh I posted this [ __ ]
by the way dude like when I talk about
this like haters and [ __ ] I you know I
say haters but like people often think
that I'm like like if I say I'm a Diva
they'll be like oh you really is a diva
[ __ ] this [ __ ] like this is a
comedy podcast okay and I don't like to
say this because I've liked it I don't
like to peel back the curtain I don't
like the BTS [ __ ] with this [ __ ] but
like dude I'm gonna put back the current
a little bit hey breaking news I'm a
comedian dude I posted a reel the other
day about [ __ ] um Eric was talking
about how uh uh I said I don't know if I
would get a vasectomy I don't like
vasectomies that's so weird for me and
then Eric was like well it's you know
women take the pill and he was trying to
[ __ ] white night it all up and just
be a hero and [ __ ] and talk about how
you know the pill is is not natural and
it affects women's bodies and I'm just
and I go like this Eric shut the [ __ ] up
like as uh like let's keep it a silly
goose and keep it moving and also I was
playing a character of a guy that's like
now don't ruin it because we like to you
know we like to splurt but dude my whole
thing is like
pull out
loud is it that much great to sport
inside pull out
you're gonna cut inside between my balls
and my [ __ ]
or am I just gonna back up lil and
splurt right
and and bro the comments on my reel on
the [ __ ] it was on Kingston Wing when
I did it the comments in my reel is like
wow Chris unfollowed like hey you got
the wrong guy dude we're having fun stop
taking it seriously and then like it is
unbelievable the [ __ ] you can't post
a [ __ ] single thing without people
just being so angry not funny you got to
draw the line somewhere not funny Chris
and everyone's like unfollow Chris Love
Eric hey White Knight
like dude we're all having fun joking
Eric laughed Brendan laughed everyone
Nick laughed chin lap everyone in a room
laugh
yeah man
it's a shame you can't own 100 of what
you say you can only own 50 of it
because the 50 of the other on the other
owner of the 50 other 50 Cent is the
people who hear it
huh everyone's mad no matter what it's
all good my babies I gotta see this
[ __ ] smile movie dude I gotta see it
the marketing on the smile movie is
[ __ ] unbelievable did you see the
people at the baseball games and [ __ ]
just like this behind the home plate
wow that doesn't even look like a smile
I guess it's like this
wow that's the scariest thing of all
time dude no [ __ ] if I was a kid and
I saw that I wouldn't have been able to
sleep for weeks and I'm not joking
I get so scared of [ __ ] anything to
do with a mouth or lips or smiling or
anything like that like people go oh
clowns are scary and they kind of are
but it's because they smile bro Smiles
are creepy as [ __ ] you know why because
if you're smiling you're hiding some
[ __ ] that's what I'm doing bro I'm
rushing about it right I'm rushing about
it
Russians don't smile for any reason
unless they're genuinely actually really
happy or laughing if you walk up to a
Russian and you're like hey what's up
nice to meet you they go well what the
[ __ ] you want from me bro I'm rushing I
get it if you're smiling and we just met
you're that happy
oh
no you want my insides
right
so that movie's smile is just creepy and
I'll tell you man they tried to make the
trailer creepy the trailer's creepy but
bro the people behind the dugouts and
[ __ ] and somebody did it behind Good
Morning America or whatever they were
behind Hoda just like this
that's scary as [ __ ] with an umbrella
because it was raining like like they
they knew it was inconvenient but they
had to get there and smile into the
camera yeah I know it's raining it sucks
but we still got to be creepy even
creepier dude there's another dude
standing up with like a pear-shaped body
just smiling like bro you want to get a
smile extra scary put it on a [ __ ]
pear-shaped body
with a medium shirt on where his guts
kind of still bro it was so scary man
and so I've got to see the movie but am
I gonna wait till it gets out into the
[ __ ] home yeah I am because he waits
he doesn't go to the movie theater
because he waits
that movie's gonna [ __ ] be really uh
they're making actually some good horror
movies finally I heard I haven't seen
this movie terrifier but my [ __ ] the
producer of my other show uh Lifeline
one of The Producers he [ __ ] he said
it's pretty good and it's like a horror
movie that they that was like an
independent movie to me for 35 000
um that they it was such a success which
I don't know how but it that they
crowdfunded a sequel another sequel's
coming out it's called terrifier and
then the sequel is obviously called
terrifyer too and
um
yeah dude I just uh think that uh they
make a lot of good horror movies now and
I wonder what that is horror and
thrillers like I saw I I
um
I I saw oh by the way the lifeline
episode is October 19th uh the live one
you could sign up for uh get tickets
there it's a live one you can call in
for us uh and we can uh do a little bit
of more of a deep dive into your life
but uh you can get tickets uh at
watchlifeline.com
uh it's me and my brother will take your
phone calls and all that [ __ ] oh can we
just stop though and talk about for real
this is incredible Adnan Syed is is like
they just go 20 years later they just go
Psych
yeah you can go get a Big Mac or
anything whatever
Adnan Saeed 20 years later they go
Psych
he was he was they they said he killed
his girlfriend
um
you know poor girl
bro and like the prosecution
was just like not given all the info out
why are they do I I guess it was 1999 so
they didn't know that people were going
to get exposed right because the
internet was just new but like oh hey
Min Lee
but like dude you're gonna get caught
and dude Adnan Syed didn't do it and
there's proof now they didn't even have
a re-trial they were just like
oh dude we actually can release him
um based on the psych clause
we just issued him and we've got a court
ordered oopsie Daisy
and if we just get Adnan and his guys to
sign right here we're just gonna we're
not even gonna try him again we're just
gonna throw it out because of the psych
clause
anyway sign there and then the judge can
judge can we get you to write an Oopsy
Daisy please
and I add 9 Syed is gone dude
and uh
just [ __ ] tossed it out
that's [ __ ] crazy bro give him
millions and they just passed a [ __ ]
thing too where they're like oh well we
can't
there's some loophole where if they just
let him out or something and don't admit
fault
they ca he can't sue him and I'm just
like
first he's first of all he got his whole
life he's like 40 right
dude
Sue those where is it Baltimore sue them
dude Baltimore's got no money you know
get the rest of it and wrap Baltimore up
that's it dude Baltimore the city of
Baltimore should just be like ah we
[ __ ] up here's all the here here give
it to him in briefcase just whatever you
have left just get we're actually in a
lot of debt we want to transfer the debt
over to you too but the [ __ ]
according to the the psych the psych
clause and the judge signed the oopsie
Daisy we can't do that so here's the
rest we have left we have 13
586 dollars
and that's a wrap for Baltimore dude
that's it that's it we just became
[ __ ] Richmond real quick or
whatever's close we're now part of
Washington DC I don't even know
we're Orange in New Jersey
uh we we're not [ __ ] it we [ __ ] up
dude we try we were trying so hard and
now we [ __ ] up with the odd nancyed
[ __ ] they're not even the killer we're
not even gonna get the real killers
we're [ __ ] we have no money Adnan if you
want to find them and shoot them like
Hunger Games go for it there's no laws
because Baltimore doesn't exist anymore
oh [ __ ] dude I mean real talk man I
would
my god dude if I got in
like imagine being [ __ ] dude there
like what's the percentage of people who
are wrongfully convicted it's like too
high what one is too high but like
imagine bro and you come out in 20 years
dude I'm killing everybody
I'm Deadpool oh well well I got how many
killings can I do now what what do I
have stacked right
like what what I've got some uh uh what
do you call it you got debt with me
how many cars what do you get for
robbing a bank
15 years I'm gonna rob a bank and have
five years left over what can I do can I
like uh what do I get to do I can
[ __ ] smack a few people I don't like
right so let me do that I'll tell you
what I'll rob a bank look the other way
and then I'm gonna go smack a few people
not in the bank robbery that doesn't get
all of that is with the bankrupt so
that's what I get now and that dude
[ __ ] gets the 13 586 at Baltimore
game [ __ ] gets to rob a bank and
smack a few [ __ ]
because this dude I mean he might have
missed his parents Diane this dude might
have missed you know what I mean no he
could have been a family man and had a
kid that's my heart man my heart breaks
for that [ __ ]
Court Judge Melissa Finn ordered that
science conviction be vacated and she
approved the release of the oopsie Davey
affidavit
um now 20 41 year old who I spent more
than two decades Behind Bars Jesus
Christ
Finn ruled that here he gets to rob a
bank make 13 586 and also smack four
people
he's always maintained his in a sense
received widespread attention in 2014
when the debut that's right cereal I saw
cereal now they're going to make another
cereal I remember watching that serial
podcast or thinking of or listening to
that cereal podcast and not knowing
either way dude and they didn't know
either way either that's the thing about
the [ __ ] documentaries and [ __ ] it's
like I know it's the best thing to do is
to be unbiased and that was really good
that serial podcast because it was
unbiased but but by the last episode
what's your [ __ ] opinion man wrap it
up like let me [ __ ] like I've been
I've been with you for 18 episodes on
some of these bullshits and like then at
the end you're just gonna be like we
don't know at least lie and be like he
probably did it
you led me down a path it's like going
to [ __ ] you know what I mean it's
like me when I was trying to find the
[ __ ] uh
who gives a [ __ ] I don't want to finish
that sentence this is this podcast you
know and this is why you ride with me we
love it dude we love it and I appreciate
you so much and I [ __ ] love my fans
and I love when you [ __ ] they're not
you're not fans bro we're all building a
log cabin one day on that tall grass we
got to join the cult [ __ ] shirts
and it's a beautiful thing man you like
And subscribe and it's a beautiful thing
and let me tell you something dude this
YouTube channel has stayed at 596 000
subscribers and if that's it that's it
dude
that's how big the cult is
but also share it and grow it you know
because if a cult's not grown we die we
go down in flames
um
so yeah I uh
I don't know
foreign
thing here beyond meat exact exec
accused of biting man's nose outside a
game I mean the [ __ ] title of that
you know what game just a game
this is from Associated Press a game
like be more specific a little bit
outside Nick's game whatever the [ __ ] it
was
Fayetteville Arkansas
an executive of vegan food products
company has been charged with felony
battery and making it terroristic threat
oh he must have been White
that's why they throw that around for
whites now to make it even you know
I'll tell you one thing if he wasn't
white they wouldn't have said
terroristic
because they know what's up
uh a terroristic threat after a fracas
outside a football game what's a fracas
a tussle
then they're gonna say a game and use
the word fracas
[ __ ] god breathe my anus in and
um outside a football game in which he
accused was he's accused of biting a
man's nose that's hilarious he's an
owner of a vegan [ __ ] place and he's
out here eating real meat
beyond meat cheap beyond meat well we
meant by beyond meat we meant noses
uh uh beyond meat chief operations I
mean that whole [ __ ] the four words
together you know
beyond meat chief operations officer
officer
I mean dude you made a fake Burger
off the [ __ ] gall
hi I'll be your comedy officer this
evening me
hi guys it's Crystal Lee I'm backstage
want to bring up some other com Comics
first but and I just want you to know
before you get to see me the uh the the
the the the the chief operations officer
of Comedy crystalia
so anyway beyond meat
chief operations officer Doug Ramsey too
many names
has been accused of a road rage attack
outside Saturday's game between the
Arkansas Razorbacks and Missouri State
Bears in Fayetteville Arkansas
ah police records report says that the
53-year-old Fayetteville man attacked
another man who tried to inch in front
of him
two males with I mean a police officer
responding to the reported disturbance
arrived to find two males with bloody
faces okay
that man and witness also reported
Ramsey threatening to kill the man I
mean I don't I don't like that you get
extra heat for threatening to kill
somebody during a fight like that's what
a fight is like you better be fighting
hard like what are we doing here if
we're on the street having a fracas
what are we doing here we're not pulling
punches I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you I
won't probably because it'll get broken
up or I'll slip and hit my head or some
[ __ ] you know
but if there's a frackis best believe
I'm gonna try to end your life during
this fracas
could you imagine I'd kill someone by
mistake or right or I'm on trial for it
later and they use this as evidence well
you know he said
I was like can we get the judge to
[ __ ] sign the oopsie Daisy
um beyond meat has not responded to the
whole thing about it's called beyond
meat you know beyond meat has not
responded to messages
wow dude the guy bit his [ __ ] nose
not really beyond that much meat
Beyond
beyond meat
oh I'm just like
we got people out here biting I mean if
I had to rate my Jamaican accent I would
say um Elite
I mean what a dancehall
the islands all have in common
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
accent Just go with it ah
I am the island bombing
Willy committing the color Broken Eyes
[Music]
dude
shinsee his face didn't change at all
the whole time unbelievable dude he
didn't hit notes with his countenance
unbelievable dude the guy does a
uh what does Patois what do they all
have in common Drake I'm the Drake I'm
the Jamaican Drake
calling me being being up them tangs bit
big up them things Drake boyakaboya
cotton
accent I would say um Elite the guy from
the office if I have to rate my Jamaican
accent I would say I'm Elite
well what what
bombing I mean what a dance hall the hum
of the crowd the islands all have in
common
uh
[Applause]
Cincy what he's doing with his left hand
can call me Shabba Ranks Drake
this is [ __ ] Chet Hanks dude
you know this guy I need Kamoze you're
not even snow
big open
Informer you know synonymous down
didn't think I knew that I know it
what's the [ __ ] Hickam neon step word
her up picotine will be on the area
where there are still living like that
how I know what Bo don't know touch them
up and go uh oh dude touch them up
so when you hear me speaking a Jamaican
accent Just go with it I mean uh
Just Go With It pleading
please just go with it you know I can be
doing it
bombing I am the island
like move on to something else I
don't
know
dude dirtier
Sean uh what's his name
who's the
[ __ ] Jamaican guy Sean John no no
that's the clothing thing is it Sean
who's the [ __ ] Jamaican guy
uh the one that goes with that big
[ __ ] with the beaker on his [ __ ]
thing he's a good looking dude but the
[ __ ] God damn it what's his name let
me I gotta look it up dude this is the
annoying part too because Big Jim uh
reggae artist because some of you guys
know who I'm talking about in what I'm
listening to
Sean Paul dude
John that Paul you do bro if your name's
Sean Paul don't say it like John Paul
you know
seven best reggae artists of all time
right here
I just can't with reggae man
um
every song
and then Bob Marley and then they'll be
like man it's crazy how political his
music is and then you'll be like oh
really play it we jamming like
ah we're German in the name of the law
SI not political jamming
with German
hey
not political oh yeah
so political because they will be on the
area word I'm up
15 greatest and most famous Reggae
singers of all time here you go here we
go by
hellomusictheory.com run another
websites
um here we go
someone can call me racist from for all
this for sure one Bob Marley great
obviously one of the most famous artists
of all time number two
Peter Tosh and that's how you know
that reggae
I mean who the [ __ ] is Peter Tosh am I
an idiot let's go to number three
Desmond Decker heard of that one
Gregory Isaacs heard of that one okay so
number two I didn't hear but Jimmy Cliff
never heard of him
have you
I am feeling very Olympic today well
um not not that uh Dennis Brown don't
know him
that was Cool Runnings yeah so racist
that they put that in the clip loving
it it is so Jamaican to make a song and
start it by saying love and hate here's
another one uh seven Burning Spear
this is called
Rasta business dude it's one of my top
10 albums of all time and that's all
I've heard and that's all I know about
it I'll never hear any more of it dude
that is unbelievable dude oh yeah we
dumb and love on the hit
oh number eight dude is called toots
that's the band name dude Calvin could
be in that one huh
that's toots dude wow dude
[Music]
oh dude Toots and the May talls that's
what it's called dude I mean ah same
song
oh wow this one's the [ __ ] well I gotta
get into reggae music this guy's name
Sizzla oh dude was eating at a
restaurant and got his name so uh let's
see this one
okay
Sizzla I'm living
2015 it came out
this is the beginning of the thing it's
just wind
and fire crackling burning out
I can't wait to hear the beginning
[Music]
here's bunny Whaler
here we go
it's called liberation
[Music]
ah same band as all the other guys
we're really busy man we're really busy
we booked till
2075 man
every night and also matineesman
[Laughter]
in this guy is the guy who hits the team
drums man
it's us to rebook till 2000. ah we just
got a phone call we booked till 3023 man
foreign
and also
we also did all the songs in a Rasta
businessman
here we go Marcia Griffith Marsha
Griffiths
[Music]
it's very good dude leave it to the
chick to keep it real Ziggy Marley heard
of him let's do it
oh I love it wind again
it sounds pretty different to me Janet K
okay a little bit still sounds like a
little bit like it Shaggy dude you know
number 14. Shaggy's always like this
yeah
his [ __ ] sounds different
oh yeah no but the best was Shabba Ranks
we're Shabba Ranks Shabba Ranks nobody
was better than Shabba Ranks and of
course he's not even on this list dude
[ __ ] all that dude Shabba Ranks was the
[ __ ] dude how much is Shabba rank [ __ ]
nine women
[Laughter]
says [ __ ] nine women dude and he's
like 60.
and he's toward the world dude and he
only wears pants whenever he's around
him
[Music]
wow dude
um
wow dude that's unbelievable the
Jamaican the Jamaican uh Drake
let's do some deserved scales
um here we go or I should always click
on these earlier but I don't so it's all
good it is what it is
I'm going to click on them all now
and I got them all here
riding a motorcycle into you man I saw a
[ __ ]
guy riding a motorcycle at his wedding
once and it was a clip on
um one of the old uh what do you call it
uh Bob Saget um What's that show Money
America's Funniest Home Videos and my
God it was it was between that and a
skiing video that made me laugh the
hardest the guy put his bride on um a
motorcycle and he was they were indoors
and he went to drive away and he hit the
gas too hard and he drove into the set
of the wedding and just took it out and
the wife fell and he fell they weren't
that hurt but oh my God it was so
[ __ ] funny dude that one and another
one where a guy was skiing down from the
mountain and he was skiing and it was
this beautiful shot of the guy skiing
and he was doing these cool kind of
[ __ ] these you know the back and
forth [ __ ] and right as he got close to
the cameraman he says sorry Chris and
runs I'm doing it like couldn't stop
himself and apologize before
dude I was rolling around in the [ __ ]
and I I've never seen either of them if
anybody sees either of those send them
to me I have to see those again my God
that sorry Chris one I think his name is
Chris because I I remember was it my
name too but dude my brother and I
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] we were laughing so
hard I would love to send it to Matt
okay riding a Motocross into your
wedding what could go wrong example of
how not to enter your wedding I mean to
[Music]
oh uh divorce
holy [ __ ]
well [ __ ] ass horn too
God I hope that guy's okay
Jesus Christ
I didn't wear a [ __ ] helmet either
that's that's that's
[ __ ] God damn dude
driving into the bush of a cactus oh no
dude this guy got stuck at all the
cactus dude this guy wow man what a
dum-dum
oh I hope you like that sticky icky
wow the gates didn't stop that huh
that's a good one uh using a potato as a
suppressor oh wow okay
I Hear What I Call rednecks on love it
when it's a I love it when it's a
southern guy dude
makes it that much better because around
here when I call redneck song
dude he's got a potato on the end of his
[ __ ] long I mean it's a sniper right
there
I mean uh King of the Hill
what the [ __ ] is he saying
what happened
oh my God his gun broke oh my god dude
a tripod
oh my god look right here I want to put
a diet in the rain and see what happened
there's peanut butter tripod let's put
upside down put a camera on that man
well that was good I mean that was like
a six just because it wasn't that funny
he missed the garbage truck
what's this one
sound I like when there's sound dude oh
there's a little sound ah wait a minute
I just kind of caught it
oh no he's driving
oh my
God
[ __ ] dude so [ __ ] on his scooter
already and then takes the trash and
he's trying to [ __ ] throw it that's
it
he has a helmet so we laugh hard to be
good oh my god dude that's a [ __ ]
nine wow so deserves it Guy hey Guy wait
till next week
you know it was just like a bag of
Chinese food uh what could go wrong here
we go
guy gets out of the truck out of the gas
station
walking around the front of the truck of
the gas station trips on the
oh
[ __ ] dude
[Laughter]
right holy [ __ ] [ __ ] he could have
bro this guy could have died
oh wow his [ __ ] friend took so long
to get a car oh those are his parents
probably holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I hope he's
okay I didn't mean to laugh that hard I
mean this guy took a tumble and trust in
God
trips and
boom oh dude he's out oh and he just
wipes his shorts well this guy
whoa dude
yeah
I mean well I said we said karma for the
parking job yeah I get that Karma
c-a-r-m-a
um wow dude
hope he's okay look at everyone
congregate
um I think I did everyone there let's
look at some tinders and then we're off
um
by the way the CBD code
uh works if you go to the link on there
if you like CBD I use that pure Spectrum
stuff and it's great I get 10 off from
my listeners with code congrats you can
do that
um you guys rock uh we got that uh the
merch look at this brown shits right
here
the life rips we got the sweatpants that
go with it too remember we got to get
this merch and then [ __ ] wear it at
other people's shows bro right there
that line that Periwinkle shits can't
it's all inside out great worst
presentation
um and the jackets are live now too and
uh I'm loving being on tour I will be in
Peoria
and uh
Savannah and Raleigh uh coming up so do
that go there and um Boston and uh
Denver and I got a bunch of other ones
Albany so uh hit the crystalia.com the
website and see where I'm at near you
and uh remember life ribs well that's it
for the YouTube episode if you want you
have to if you want you still have to uh
go on over to patreon.com crystalia for
the raw uncut unedited version of the
podcast and not only do you get that you
get every episode on an edited
unfiltered and you get the uh no ads and
[ __ ] like that and then also you get
another episode a month for for uh
signing up and it's all that for just
six dollars we have about 17 episodes
now that are only patreon so you can go
watch them all right now if you sign up
and do a whole day of it dude uh and
then also we do different things like we
have a segment called review mode and we
do different things and I got a podcast
with Kristen on there that I did once or
and I think I'm gonna do it again so uh
patreon.com crystallia thanks a lot guys
foreign
[Music]